رفعت السلطات والباكستانيه حاله التاهب
الى اقصى درجاتها مع اقتراب جدار اعصار
بيبار جوي من السواحل الباكستانيه مع توقع
مركز الارصاد الباكستاني بان يضرب هذا
الاعصار السواحل الباكستانيه الهنديه خلال
ساعات المساء يقول مختصون الارصاد في
باكستان بان هذا الاعصار هو الاكثر من
الاعاصير اطاله او بقاء داخل بحر العرب
وضع اثر على الاف وعشرات الالاف من
الصيادين الذين
حضرت السلطات نزولهم وعملهم الى داخل
البحر منذ نحو خمسه ايام وهو ما اثر بشكل
كبير على مستويات الدخل لعشرات الالاف من
العاملين في الصيد في مدينه كراتشي عاصمه
اقليم السن والتي يقطن فيها اكثر من عشرين
مليون شخص هذه القوارب وهذه السفن منعت من
الدخول الى البحر مع اقتراب حاله
الامواج الكبيره التي ارتفعت الى نحو
ثمانيه وعشره امتار في داخل
البحر وهو ما اثر بشكل كبير جدا على مسار
هذه القوارب تقول السلطات انه من المتوقع
ان يضرب الاعصار في ساعات المساء مسببا
فيضانات وامطار غزيره بالاضافه الى رياح
شديده وعاليه السرعه قد تؤثر على الاجسام
غير الثابته كانت السلطات الباكستانيه قد
قامت باجلاء اكثر من 90 الف شخص من
المناطق الساحليه المتوقع ان تتاثر
بالاعصار الى مناطق امنه داخل مدينه
كراتشي وهذا العمل قامت به السلطات محليه
بالاضافه الى قوات الجيش وقوات الامن
الباكستانيه سمير النمري الجزيره مدينه
كراتشي جنوب باكستان